okay Dr Anthony fouchy now admitting
social distancing wasn't based on
science fouchy telling a house committee
this week the idea standing six feet
apart quote just sort of appeared the
shocking admission comes nearly four
years after statements like
this every aspect of that ending the
covid outbreak in 30 days has some
aspect of it of physical separation
whether that's avoiding crowds whether
that's staying six feet away from people
whether that's doing teleworking all of
it does that that's our most important
tool here with reaction Fox News medical
contributor Dr Mark seagull so Dr
seagull I want to get your reaction but
do you remember the Great Links that
schools went to to separate desks to put
up plexiglass the links that we all went
went through when we were in the grocery
store standing six feet apart people
would yell at you if you got too close
to them all of that for nothing there's
no scientific proof that that even
worked it came from somewhere angsley
and I'll tell you where came from in a
minute but what I want to say is the
biggest damage was done by extending it
past a couple of weeks to slow down the
initial surge of hospitalizations in New
York that we didn't know what to do a
but the problem is the science that
started to emerge after that is contrary
to what this came from it didn't come
from nowhere the way Dr fouchi said it
came from 1918 science that's what it
was in 1918 we had a flu virus which
actually didn't go as far as Co didn't
spread all over over the place it rode
along the flu on large droplets so in St
Louis Dr ma starkoff who was the City
Health commissioner and in Washington
state Thomas Tuttle epidemiologist they
shut things down and they had an impact
but it's a different virus and here as
early as February 2020 Angley we found
out in Nebraska and I was out there
interviewing the researchers they said
CO's all over the room CO's spreading
through communities so the idea idea of
social distancing didn't come out of
nowhere but it came out of 1918 and we
already knew better and you made the
most important point of all it wasn't it
was one thing to say six feet apart but
a lot of poor schools couldn't do that
so they closed and they missed the main
thing they should have done which was
ventilation opening Windows that
actually has an impact so he wrote Along
on 1918 science and stuck with it just
it's so upsetting because um we went
through so much during that period and
it seems like every time we learned
something new from Dr fouchy it was all
made up I mean didn't even have
Direction there was no science there and
I got to also point out I and many
others warned in early 2020 that it was
going to have extreme collateral damage
on our children that they were going to
have learning problems as a result
social he's saying there's no there's no
proof of that there's total proof of
that and it took the New York Times
three years to come along and agree with
let's talk let's talk about jelly roll
he's been here at Fox and Friends and he
connects with his audience he's a rapper
he's a singer um and you know very
famous throughout the country now he's
been in prison he sold drugs uh says he
can't even vote anymore because of his
his wrap sheet a long wrap sheet he's
gotten clean now and now he's going to
Capitol hilly talk to Senate the senate
about this uh F off fentol act which
will Implement sanctions to reduce the
flow of Fentanyl and he tells his story
listen to this and we'll talk about it
on the back
end I've attended more funerals than I
care to share with y'all this committee
I could sit here and cry for days about
the caskets I've carried of people out
loved dearly deeply in my soul good
people I was a part of the problem I am
here now standing as a man that wants to
be a part of the
solution wow what's your reaction I love
the power of that the personal appeal
that he's been through it he says
cooking these things together in his own
kitchen the way the drug dealers are
putting it together in these 10- foot
Labs very very powerful his song save me
uh need a favor all speaking please save
me God before I die from this is going
to have an impact I like this bill a lot
fendo fendor fenel the problem is and
it's bipartisan the problem is drugs
sanctions like this aren't the answer
are they they're a step in the right
direction the answer is closing the
Border no matter what happens fenel will
Zoom across the border no matter how
many Financial sanctions you put on it
and by the way now there's something
called benzo dope which combines fenel
with something like Xanax a strong Xanax
so even if I use Naran to reverse it it
won't work we'll be more and more
overdose deaths from people stopping
breathing and the only solution is to
close the border I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley aart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling
analysis